では よろしくお願いします
今日は特別講演ということで
年一回関西で法話講演会やってますので
今日はその日なんですけど
まあ現状を配慮して 一応ネットで発信することにいたしました
では そういうことでよろしくお願いします
はい これはまあ 1年前から考えていたテーマなんですけど
信頼される人間になるということで
不動の信頼関係をどうやって築くのかということで
あの まあまあ あまり深く仏教の話にも入らないで
まあ軽々とタッチして話を進めたいとは思います
はい まずは信頼される人間と言っても
これは結局はもともと人間関係の話なんですね
人間関係で自分が信頼されているという状況が必要というか
期待しているということでね
なんでそんなにも人間関係を築くでしょうかね
それって至って単純なことで
この孤独で生きられないんですね
人間にとっては 他人との関係を結んで社会組織を作って生活しているんですね
人間は人間なりに社会組織をいろいろ作って
ありすぎでしょ 地球上の人間が一つの社会になった方が一番やりやすいんだけど
そうはなってないんだよ
いろんな組織も数えられないぐらいいっぱいあるんですね
一人の人がいくつかの組織に入っている場合もあるしね
動物の中でも群れを作って生活するということはよくあることでね
じゃあ単独で生活する動物もいるでしょうし
いることはいるんだけどね
結構凶暴なんですね 単独動物はね
しかし 仏教でいうこの孤独で生きられないということは
そういう社会システムじゃないんですね
この肉体 体持っている生命自体が成り立たないんですね
単細胞ウイルスにしてもね
ウイルスはもうまあ生命かどちらかよくわからん中途半端な存在ですけど
ウイルスにしても単独で生き延びないんですね
他のどこかの細胞に依存しないと
だから細菌もそうでしょうし
自分たちだけでは生きていられないんですね
だからウイルスすら細菌すら単独で生活できんですよ
だから それぐらい幅広く仏教はこの問題を見ているんですね
まあだからこの慈しみの瞑想などなどをね
教えているのは この事実を認めましょうということで
そこで仏教的な問題は
この存在欲があることなんですね
生命にはどんな生命にも存在欲があります
で 生きていきたいという気持ちがありますから
なんとか工夫して生き続けなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 人間関係の機動力っていうのは存在欲になってるんですね
要するに煩悩なんですね
だから初めから仏教は煩悩は否定しているんだからね
ここら辺でテーマをやめた方がいいということになりますけど
だから存在欲を応援することになりますね
この話をつけちゃうと
それで 存在欲だけではなくて
様々な感情ね 煩悩が割り込むんですね
だからこの人間関係がこの感情の関係になってるんですね
だからうまくいってないんですね
例えば欲があると この欲の関係を築こうとする
怒りがあると怒りの関係を築こうとする
無知があると無知の人間関係を築こうとする
それで もう まあ築きますけど
作りますけど うまくはいかないんですね
一番わかりやすいのは
この政党などは この欲の組織なんですね
権力欲やらね いろいろがあって
まあ別にそれ以上素晴らしい目的であの組織を作ってるとは思えないんだけどね
そこで若者もそれぞれ自分の好みによって組織作るし
まあその場合も感情が割り込んでいるんですね
だから 人間関係自体が感情でやってるんだから
どんな関係であってもトラブルがあるんですね
いろんな問題が起こるんですね
そこで感情をまとめると
エゴなんですね ということは
社会組織っていうのはエゴ同士の組織なんですね
同じタイプのエゴがある人々は組織作るんです
そこで エゴ同士でお互い対立したり
あなたより私の方が上やと言いたかったりするんですね
だから支配したり 支配されたり
管理したりされたり いろんなことはまあ起こりますよ
まあエゴの戦いだからね
まあそういうことで まああまりまあうまくいかないんですね
はい 次のスライドに続きます
そこで私は次元の苦しみというタイトルにしたんですね
人間には苦しみがあるんですね
一元的な苦しみというのは生老病死ですね
それから逃げる人はいません
生まれると同時にセットで生老病死がついているんですね
だから 生きること自体が生老病死なんですね
で 命ある限りそこからは逃げられないんですね
そこで それに加えて新しい苦しみがあるんですね
誰もあまり生老病死はその苦しみだと思わないんですね
相対的に苦しみと 例えばすごく年取ったら苦しいと思っちゃうんですね
でも 毎日年取ることは大変危険であるとは思わないんですね
死にかけてくると怯えて苦しいと思っちゃうんですね
だから 毎日死に向かい迎えていくこと approaching
the death ということがあまり苦しみだと思わない
毎日 毎日 日々 日々近寄っていくんですね
死に それも考えてみれば怖いもんなんですね
寿命が縮みますからね
何にストップで それで十分なのに
人間が二次的な苦しみも作るんです
悩み 苦しみ 落ち込み 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ 苦しみ 争い
奪い合い そういう苦しみも起こるんだ
それは人間が作るんです
動物の中でもあるんですけど
人間の場合はもうひどいんですね
戦争まで考えるんだからね
だからこの苦しみが足らないんですね
人間には だから一元的な苦しみで心配するべきなのに
ものすごい苦しみを作って作って作りまくって
さらに苦しむんですね
ですから この人間関係も結局は悩み苦しみの原因になるんですね
わかりやすく言えば 人間にとってはこの幸福を作ることはできないみたい
人間何を作ってもそこから苦しみが生まれる
だから社会組織作っても
そこから苦しみが現れてくるんですね
だから 社会組織で信頼される人間になりたいんだけど
それはものすごい後で
まあもうすごい短く簡単で話は進めます
そこで私たちは考えるべきことは
では悩み苦しみの原因にならないように作る人間関係があるんですかと
それは大変な大きな問題なんですね
ほとんどないと言えるぐらいですね
例えば我々仏教の世界で生きているんだから
仏教の世界でもいろんな組織があるんですね
若者の組織 お寺にあるんですね
おばあちゃんたちの組織
みんなこの善行をするために集まって組織作ってるんですね
で それだったらすごく清らかな心で作った組織でしょ
やっぱり自我がある場合あるんですね
喧嘩するんですよ 若者が組織作っても
まあ年寄りの組織よりは明るいことは明るいんだけど
どうもどこかで喧嘩になっちゃって
また我々坊主がいて 割り込んでもう抑えてあげなくちゃいけなくなる場合もあります
だから 例えば慈しみを
慈悲喜捨を実践する組織を作りましょうと思っても
その場合は自我がないでしょ
慈悲喜捨の場合は まあ信頼できない組織を作ったらどうかで
あなたより私の方が慈悲喜捨をしっかり実践していますよと言っちゃったら
それでもうトラブルだからね
大変なことになるんですね
ですから まず我々はこの基本的なポイントを繰り返して理解しなくちゃいけない
単独で命は成り立たない
人間に限ったものじゃない
存在欲があってもなくても
死を迎えるまで命をつなぐべきです
だから これは逃げられないんですね
で 命が形成されたら それは壊れて分解するまで維持する
しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 存在欲がない人もいるし
ある人 ない人っていうのは悟った人々ですけど
悟った人でもわざわざと体を壊すことはしないんですね
そういう意欲はないんです
ですから やっぱり体を維持することになるんですね
で 存在欲ある人々はやっぱり頑張って命をつなぐことに結構ハチャメチャ頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
というわけで 我々は誰一人も
いくら大変だと思っても
この人間関係築かないでいることはできないんです
で どうしても人間関係作った方が良いということになります
はい それであの答えなんですけど
慈しみ だからこの我々は組織作る場合はこの慈しみを基にした方がものすごく良い
いわゆるベターな組織を作られるんですね
完全ということでもないんだけどね
生かしてくれることに
だから無数の生命が自分を生かしてるんですね
神様じゃないんです  de無数の生命が我々を生かしてくれているんですね
ですから 我々の義務なんですね
全ての生命に対してありがたい助け
お世話になっているという気持ち
慈しみの気持ちを育てることが根本的な義務なんです
生命の そうなると 全ての生命のおかげで私は生きているんだと言うと
自分のエゴが暴走しないんです
エゴはあっても張らなくなっちゃうんですね
健康になるんですね それでエゴが暴走しないと
怒り 嫉妬 欲などなども暴走しないんです
だから怒りで暴走するということはエゴなんです
欲が暴走するということもエゴなの
欲しいものはどうしても手に入りたい
入れたいと 自分のものにしたいと思ったら
エゴがあるんです だからエゴを抑えておけば
他の感情も暴走しないということになります
そういうことで 安穏で落ち着いて楽しく生きることができるようになるんですね
慈しみの人は おかげさまで生きているのだという気持ちを忘れません
だから まず我々はおかげさまで生きているんだという気持ちを育てなくちゃいけないんですね
はい 次に行きます はい
次のポイントは これは選択ではなくて
これ えっと プライオリティ順位ですね
あの 何でしたっけ？優先順位なんですね
自分が生かされてるんですね
他の生命に だから この返す義務があるんです
みんなに 他の生命も生かしてあげる義務が生じているんです
それは仏教以外は他の宗教を教えてないだけなんですね
だから科学的に命を見ると
みんな他の生命に借りがあるんです
無数の生命に借りがあるんです
ですから 社会は相互依存で生きているんですね
個人には社会に対して果たさなくてはならない義務と責任というのあるんです
義務責任ない生命はいません
人間だけに限ってみても
人間は人間社会から 人間社会が生かしてるんですね
生まれる時も病院に行くんだからね
マンモス組織でしょう
で これももう長い間あらゆる研究して
いろんなことをして すごいお金を使ってできている組織なんですね
だから単純じゃないんですね
生まれると赤ちゃんが知らないんだけど
生まれた赤ちゃんにこういうマンモスな組織が助けて
命を助けてくれたという義務が生じている
知ってるんです 赤ちゃん何もわからないんだから
誰も赤ちゃんに義務を押し付けることはしませんだけど
物事をわかってくれると
自分で判断して生きられるようになると
先にそれを教えなくちゃいけないんですね
一人で生きてるんではないんだよと
理性のある人は自分の義務責任をまず果たすんですよ
だからもう文句言ってる場合じゃないんですね
自分の義務と責任 まず果たしていかなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の人間関係を明確にしますね
じゃあどうやって義務を果たすのかと
わからないんですね たくさん生命がいるんだから
無数の生命がいるんだから
だからこの場合はできるだけ人間だから人間組織にリミットしなくちゃいかんですね
人間に対する義務を果たすといっても
日本人に生まれたら日本国に対する義務を果たしたあともどうすればいいというはてなになっちゃうんですね
そうすると日本国が別に大したことを期待してないんです
あんたいてもいなくても
別に行った来も帰ってもないよと
いう程度ですよ 日本国は個人に対しては
死んじゃったら死んじゃったともうそれで名前取り消すだけ
それで終わり だから我々は義務を果たす場合は
国に対する義務って大した義務がないんです
ただ 法律だけ守れば十分です
法律を守って 普通常識的に生きれば
国に対する義務を果たしているんですね
だいたい日本社会見ると
誰だって国に対する義務を果たしているんですね
税金も払っているし まあ交通違反もしない
する人もいるんだけど
まあほとんどしないしね
で だからそこら辺で悩まなくてもいいんです
では 私は自分の義務って何ですかね？果たさなくちゃいけない義務って
そこでお釈迦様が明確にこの人間関係ということについての説法をなさっているんですね
それは本にもなってますけどね
教会出したんです サンガ出版で出したんですかね
シガラ経典の本は  角川文庫から出てますね
シガラ 成功する生き方という本ですね
はい 成功する生き方という名前で
角川角川出版社からね
角川書院角川  文庫  角川文庫の Kindle 版もありますね
Kindle 版 今半額になってます
そうですか  三百十六円
三百十六円安くなってます
はい  そこで人間関係について詳しくというかね
適当に書いてありますので
もし暇があったらお読みになってください
それで このシガラワード経典では面白いんですよ
すごく子供にもわかりやすく書くんですね
東西南北上下という六法を作るんですね
ということは どんな人間にも六法があるんです
誰にも 私には東は存在しない
西は存在して言えないんです
だから どんな人間にも六法があるんですから
誰でもこの六法から危険なことを批判受けられないようにということで
六法を守るというフレーズでお釈迦様が人間関係をについて明確に語ったんですね
そこで六法だったら三つでしょ？六つでしょ？すごくわかりやすくなるんです
じゃあ北の方にどうやってどんな義務がある？東の方にどんな義務がある？西の方にどんな義務がある？という風にリスト作られます
そこでお釈迦様はちゃんと六つ
六つ 六つ 六つ義務もリストアップしているんです
お釈迦様のリストだからそのまま守ればいいんです
だから当時の義務よりは
今の世界では義務の方がある程度で軽くなっているんです
ブッダの時代はもう厳しい社会環境でしたから
義務も厳しかったんだけど
それほどは現代はないんで
だから昔の人々より現代人に自分の義務を果たすことはすごい簡単にできると思います
仏教を知っているならば
各方向に対する義務責任を明確に語られていますということで
あの あの 今日の話の最後に一応参考に出します
はい 次のスライドに行きます
[咳払い]